it might seem like we're picking on
Raiders but in a movie that's otherwise
perfect the few flaws are really easy to
spot take for instance Indy's trip on a
Nazi submarine the key word there is on
not in with the help of a friendly sea
captain Indy steals his way into a
U-Boat to rescue Marion and defeat
belloch jumping atop it just before it
goes underwater the film then cuts to an
island where the villains planned to
open the Ark of the Covenant so how did
our soaking wet Indie survive the trip
obviously he couldn't just cling to the
Periscope and hold his breath for
hundreds of miles but from what we've
seen in the movie and even a deleted
scene that's exactly what happened it's
just a good thing nobody ever bothered
to lower the Periscope for the entire
trip or else would have to deal with the
explanation that Indie was secretly the
Lost king of Atlantis all this time